well we begin in Niger where the Army
has declared allegiance to the leaders
of a coup there the chief of staff says
he doesn't want to see conflict within
the Armed Forces president Muhammad
bazoom was detained by soldiers of his
own presidential guard on Wednesday
Ahmad Idris reports now from Abuja in
neighboring Nigeria
security and Defense Forces pledged to
crush the Mutiny the detention and
removal of President Muhammad bazoom by
the guards appointed to protect him
hours later and about turn one that
complicates and possibly ends any hope
of reinstating the deposed leader the
chief of staff of the Armed Forces
declared support for the co-leaders
saying he did not want to cause division
it was this announcement on Wednesday
that ended this year's first peaceful
transition between civilian governments
we the security Defense Forces gathered
at the National Council for the
Safeguard of the nation have decided to
put an end to the regime you are
familiar with this follows the
continuous deterioration of the security
situation the bad social and economic
management we reaffirm our support to
all commitments undertaken by Niger
it also returned soldiers to the
corridors of power an emerging Trend in
West Africa with implications not only
for the region but for the continent
amid the uncertainty a few hundred
supporters of President Muhammad bazu
marched towards the presidential Palace
in a show of defiance
warning shots from troops loyal to the
Army send them fleeing for safety
mediation from former president
muhammadu isafu failed to sway the
soldiers or secure the release of mazum
and his family the United Nations
African Union Regional block Echoes and
the United States have all demanded
bazoom's reinstatement
I spoke with President bazoom earlier
this morning and made clear that the
United States resolutely supports him as
the democratically elected President of
Niger
we call for his immediate release
we condemn any effort to seize power by
force
frustrations around unrest and uprisings
in the Sahel have been a driving force
behind cools in several West African
countries Nigeria's neighbors Mali and
Burkina Faso have seen four military
takeovers since 2020.
Western Nations particularly France and
the United States have since
increasingly relied on Niger as a base
of operations against armed groups in
the Sahel they'll hope to see Nigeria
remain a democracy as Muhammad bazum
supporters who voted him into power just
two years ago Ahmed Idris Al Jazeera
well Ahmed joins us now from Abuja in
neighboring Nigeria Ahmed as you were
just saying there in your report plenty
of uncertainty this has been a very
fluid situation for hours parts of the
government at points denying a coup
would even taking place saying bazoom is
still president what are you now hearing
basically uh things are really really
fluid in the past few hours there were
demonstrations on the streets of the
capital in yemi by Pro cool supporters
and that degenerated into
some attacks and arson as we have made
to understand and the demonstrators in
fact attacked the headquarters of the
governing party the PN de estaria in the
capital Miami and looted property from
that building it took the intervention
of security forces to despise the crowd
and that's what we fear a lot of people
fear will Niger will turn into uh
remember the governing part
I'm sorry we've just lost a connection
there to our correspondent Ahmed id
address we'll try to to get him back for
you here but in the meantime let's speak
to our correspondent Charles Stratford
who's following things also for us from
Dhaka in Senegal Charles you've been
watching the regional reaction there
broadly condemnation
yeah widespread Condon condemnation I
mean the initial lines coming out from
ecowas that's the regional body that
looks after is supposed to look after
security across the region they strong
strongly condemning what's happened in
Niger and they're saying that anybody
found responsible for harming the
president and his family and indeed the
people of Niger will be called to
account it's a similar kind of line from
the Au the African Union as well
condemning this in the strongest
possible terms we do know that the
president of Benin
um was sent to Niger yesterday in a bid
to try and negotiate
um some some way out of this crisis very
little information coming out from there
seemingly those negotiations though
failed
um I think it's also important to
recognize that um certainly a lot of
people in this region now are asking how
has this happened again let's not forget
that this is just the latest in a series
of coups that have fallen across West
Africa in the last couple of years two
in Burkina Faso two in Mali both
countries now being run by basically
military authorities and so as you can
imagine a lot of Africans are asking
well what kind of state this means for
Democratic Evolution the Democratic
process across West Africa some very
yeah a very worrying time across this
region as you can imagine we expect more
reaction in the hours and days ahead and
not just in the region but beyond Niger
has become so Central to the West's
attempts at containing militancy
militancy across the Sahel this will
have an impact on that surely
the Chinese yeah huge concerns about
security across the region there has
been a a fight now for a number of years
in a number of countries fighting what
it often described as terror terror
groups
um Isis Al-Qaeda Boko Haram we know that
there have been millions of people
affected by this civilians there are
around about 6.2 million refugees that
have suffered as a result of this crisis
and we know that Niger is has been
pivotal in that fight and it was often
described as like a last Bastion after
we saw the withdrawal of the forced
withdrawal of U.N peacekeepers in Mali
subsequent to the military coup there
similar scenario with French troops also
we know that the French and the US have
military bases in Niger so yeah this
coup has huge implications for security
across the region and potentially even
abroad as well because there's no sign
that there was any kind of winning push
being made by any of the people fighting
these Terror organizations and of course
the impact on millions of people across
the region now being called into
question the situation potentially could
deteriorate and get even worse Charles
Stratford there across that situation
for us from Dakar thank you Charles well
we've managed to get Ahmed Idris our
correspondent back on the phone from
Abuja in Nigeria Ahmed we were talking
about the protesters you were seeing
well that you were hearing about on the
streets we were watching videos of
burning tires burning cars we've also
heard defiant words from bazoom are you
concerned that things could escalate
and these are the these are the concerns
of many people both within and outside
of Indonesia that when supporters of the
Brazil government go onto the streets
and they meet these opposition
supporters or demonstrators things could
escalate and apart from that it could
also degenerate into a situation or the
the military is not completely cohesive
as as at now simply because there are
still divisions there are still troops
loyal to bazum and his government and
with one sorts of defiance from members
of the former government or the
put government that and probably we the
state may be set for some kind of
conflict within the military itself and
that could be generate into a situation
whereby there could be total breakdown
of Law and Order from the side of the
security forces and then the general
public already cases of uh into ethnic
rivalries have been ripe during the
campaign season even after the
post-election uh results were after the
after the election of the presidential
elections were announced there were
attacks and uh violence uh that followed
the announcement of Muhammad bazum as uh
as uh president-elect of Niger then and
this is a cause of worry for countries
like Nigeria that is also struggling
with its own uh security challenges uh
total breakdown of Law and Order in Asia
could mean that the fight against uh
armed groups in the region could
definitely take a North dive and that
this this will give uh these attackers
or gunmen the upper hand in attacking
community and destabilizing the region
entirely an address there with the
latest for us from Abuja in neighboring
Nigeria thank you so much Ahmed we'll be
staying across that for you in all the
latest developments here on Al Jazeera
well earlier I spoke to Bubba World
warmer he's Al jazeera's correspondent
from West Africa he told me there's
little to be surprised about when it
comes to that coup in Niger
we know that a president was
detained early morning yesterday and
there are hours passed and probably
there was such let's say dialogue
between the presidential guard and the
rest of the military uh battalions
especially outside of the capital near
me and the the military succeeded to to
avoid this Bloodshed to avoid this
confrontation as the military declared
few hours ago that they are backing the
move taken by the presidential guard so
that's where they can put
so that they can avoid any military
confrontation between their different
battalions of the Niger Army well we
know that the the presidential guard
initially said this was about economic
mismanagement because of Insurgency in
the Sahel that was also being mismanaged
we know that Nigeria is obviously in a
bit of a tough neighborhood right and
and militancy has been increased seeing
across the region so this could have
some very broad implications for a lot
of vested interests yes but Niger Ian
situation is current situation is not
different from what it has been
a lot over the last let's say 10 years
military has been ravaging the region in
in Niger as well as in Mali in Burkina
Faso and large ideas of and regions of
these countries are out of control of
the capital Authority uh and also for
economic uh situation and life
conditions they have never been quite
good individual over all its decisions
it's it's independence in 1960 uh it's
one of the poorest country it's true
it's a living it's going through a very
difficult time over the last two years
but there's nothing let's say special
about the real of Mohammed bazoom it's
not that different from the country has
lived through a lot of the reign of
muhammadu Yusuf over the last 10 years
so it's it's always like that include
that has in West Africa it's always
about
economic and uh worsening conditions
difficult uh security situation it's
something that come together with
akudata in that tradition